las expresiones cuadráticas m cuadrada
menos 4 m
45 y 6 m cuadrada menos 150 tienen un
factor binomial en común cuál es el
factor binomial que comparten muy bien
entonces te invito a que hagas una pausa
de este vídeo y trates de resolver este
problema por tu propia cuenta factor
izando estas dos expresiones ok vamos a
hacerlo juntos y vamos a tratar de
factorizar ambos en un producto de
binomios y no sé quizás otras cosas y
veremos si hay algún factor binomial en
común muy bien así que vamos a comenzar
con esta expresión m cuadrada menos 4 m
menos 45 voy a voy a repetir esta
expresión es m cuadrada menos 4 m menos
45 muy bien entonces la idea de
factorizar esto es bueno tenemos que
utilizar un hecho aquí tenemos digamos
el coeficiente de m cuadrada es 1 así
que esto lo podemos expresar de la
siguiente forma m
número que no sabemos todavía por m más
otro número que no sabemos todavía
verdad y esto es válido cuando tenemos
digamos al 1 como coeficiente de m
cuadrada cuál es la idea aquí hay b
deben satisfacer algo muy particular de
hecho este número menos 4 debe ser igual
a la suma de ahí b mientras que el
producto de ai b debe ser menos 45 así
que voy a notar eso que dije tenemos que
la suma de ahí b es menos 4 y el
producto de ai b es decir a por b debe
ser igual a menos 45 muy bien entonces
todo este problema se reduce a pensar
qué números multiplicados nos dan menos
45 y sumados menos 4 por ejemplo
podríamos pensar en 1 y 45 verdad de
hecho por ejemplo podemos ver que como
este producto es negativo entonces deben
tener signos contrarios y como esta suma
es negativa quiere decir que
el que digamos el negativo tiene un
valor absoluto mucho más grande verdad
entonces qué números multiplicados nos
dan menos 45 podríamos por ejemplo
pensar en 1 y 45 x están muy alejados
verdad la suma no nos daría menos 4
podríamos pensar en 3 y 15 pero también
siguen estando muy alejados verdad la
suma no sería menos 4 9 y 5 me parece
una buena puesta a ver pensemos por
ejemplo 5 al multiplicarlo por menos 9
en efecto nos da menos 45 por otro lado
si sumamos 5 más menos 9 lo que
obtenemos es menos 4 entonces en
realidad estos dos números nos sirven
podríamos expresar este polinomio o esta
expresión cuadrática como m5 verdad en
este caso a sería 5 y multiplicamos por
m - 9 podríamos poner m + menos 9 pero
yo creo que con esto está bien muy bien
entonces vamos ahora a analizar
qué ocurre con la otra expresión 6 m
cuadrada menos 150 entonces podemos ver
que el 6 es un factor común verdad aquí
150 lo podemos dividir entre 6 entonces
vamos a escribir esto simplemente como
6 por m cuadrada menos 6 veces porque
número nos da 150 bueno podemos ver que
esto es 6 por 25 verdad 6 por 5 son 30
llevamos 32 por 6 son 12 y 3 nos da 15
muy bien entonces ahí ya tenemos este 6
digamos como factor común eso nos dice
que podemos factorizar la verdad y
obtenemos la siguiente expresión 6 que
multiplica a m cuadrada corrijo la m m
cuadrada menos 25 y ahora puedes
observar que esto que tenemos aquí
dentro del paréntesis es una diferencia
de cuadrados así que podemos factorizar
lo como bueno digamos si esto es de la
forma cuadrada menos b cuadrada lo
podemos poner como amas b por a menos b
en este caso a ese m ibex sería 5 así
que esto es
es por m 5 que multiplica a m
menos 5 ya lo tenemos factor izado
verdad la esencia fue factorizar la
diferencia de cuadrados ahora nos
preguntamos cuál es el binomio que
tenemos en común y podemos observar que
coinciden con este binomio que es m 5
así que la respuesta es m 5 es el
binomio que tienen en común